all right mark
marco where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
originally i'm from i was born in
vermont
lived in the south bronx
moved to jersey city
and then also lived in the southern part
of jersey so i'm an east coast kid
originally
how was your family tell me about mom
and dad
um we grew up extremely poor
um i had
five brothers and two sisters
and we grew up
in richfield new jersey
my mom was a stay-at-home mom
immigrated from ireland
um
didn't have much work experience and way
too many children
and not enough money to go around
my father
was an accountant
in clark new jersey
and just never ever had enough bills to
pay
i remember early on as a childhood when
we moved out of the south bronx into
richfield new jersey
we lived in a really old house that only
my father could afford
and in that house there was no
heat
there was no hot water
and uh
we had just scrummage around and live on
food stamps and government subsidies
just to be able to eat
um
in the winter
was freezing in the state of new jersey
and we had no windows in the house and
there was no heat
and i remember me and my brothers and
my sister at the time
would just huddle around the
little
kerosene heater in the living room
and and i could remember to this day
hearing the click click click click
click and hopefully the heat would come
on and we just huddle around to get
through the night
and looking back on it i remember
i was just so afraid that one of my
brothers you know we'd wake up and
somebody wouldn't be alive
we'd maybe shower once every couple
weeks boil the hot water on the stove
and
pour it over each other in the shower
and i realized as a young age i just
didn't want my brothers and my sister to
go to bed hungry i was the middle child
and always trying to make everybody
laugh and make everything okay when
everything wasn't okay
and i started at a young age i would
deliver newspapers i would
um
sell candy bars whatever i could to
raise some money to feed my brother and
sister
and we would walk and use our food
stamps and i remember how embarrassing
it was and i was just hoping that there
was food on the table
and then my mom and my little brother
neil
he got sick
with seizures grandma petty mall
seizures and
my mom had to go to a hospital
and spent a long time
in the hospital hoping that they would
heal my brother
and i lost my mom
not forever but
for a period of time in my life
and i was a mama's boy i just shadowed
my mom i idolized my mom and one day i
woke up and my mom wasn't there
nobody explained to me what happened
and i was probably just in about fourth
or fifth grade and
that's when i realized i started turning
to the street
i started hanging around with older kids
there was a lot of violence and a lot of
kids that were rough and bullied and
picked on and beat us up and
it was terrible for me
and uh all i did was just start hustling
and if there wasn't enough food at home
i would
go to the local store or the local
delicatessen and i learned how to steal
at a young age but i wasn't stealing to
be mischief i was just stealing because
i was hungry and i wanted to feed my my
brothers and my sister
so richfield new jersey was really
really tough on me at a young age
and i didn't really know how to process
all that and one day i came home and my
mom and my dad said
we're going to move to the southern part
of new jersey because we want to get a
better life
and we moved to toms river new jersey
to try and discover a better life and i
was probably in about seventh grade
when i left richfield new jersey i was
already into dereliction and
troublemaking and running around on the
streets and staying out too late and
getting caught up with all the bad
people and it just seemed to spill over
right into seventh grade
and in seventh grade i was bullied
really bad in school and i was picked on
by kids and
i just
met a couple older kids and started
drinking
started drinking at a young age and
when drugs were presented whether it be
masculine or it'd be
weed
i just started smoking weed and started
using whatever i could to get out of my
normal state of mind
i could look back on it and try and
dissect it but i know that i just
experienced a lot of trauma a lot of
troubles
my mom wasn't always around my father
was always working
i know that my mom and my dad had a very
rough relationship they were always
fighting and
so i couldn't find my way at a young age
and i just tried to stay away from it
but always found myself in trouble
and in seventh and eighth grade i just
really started using drugs it was the
only escape i had from the reality of i
didn't want to be in my home
i didn't want to feel the pain i always
looked at everybody else and said why do
they have a good life and why am i so
troubled
and i tried my hardest as a young kid
just to get along and i always just
never
fit in
and i remember smoking weed every day
just to cope with going to school
cope with the craziness in my home
um
my brother my older brother was was
really hard to deal with he was
beating up my brother he beat up me i
remember witnessing him getting in a
fight with my mom a drug down fight and
i couldn't do anything about it
and i look back in life today and i just
see that
a lot of that just spun
just spun into a lot of drug usage
because i just wanted to escape i didn't
want to feel anymore
i know my parents did the best they
could
but at the time it just seemed like my
life was just troubled and everywhere i
went and everything that happened at a
young age and that's just too young of
an age and it's just like my childhood
was gone
one day i came home and my
mom and dad sprung on us that mom was
pregnant with the seventh kid and
we were going to be moving all the way
to california
and i remember telling my mom and my dad
why how could you have another kid i
don't understand
you can't even feed us
why would you bring another kid into the
world and i was so angry at a young age
and i was probably in about eighth grade
going into ninth grade and i was already
in trouble my grades were slipping
and
i think my parents just thought it was a
good idea to move to california
to be with my dad's only two sisters
they were the only family we had on the
east coast all the other family we had
on the west coast all the other family
we had was on the east coast all my
cousins aunts and uncles and my mother's
family
and when i came to california that's
when i i really started getting in
trouble
and i remember i was in ninth grade
i met my cousin
which was my
my father's sisters
she was married to my uncle tony
and her his daughter bella
knew some friends around the corner and
they were really into cocaine
and i tried cocaine
and i really liked the way it felt
it just removed all of my emotions and
all of my feelings
and i was in probably about ninth grade
and i got into that culture that they
had and the
selling drugs and trying to make more
money and hustle my way out of where i
was at
and
sure enough i got caught
in school
and they caught me with selling drugs
selling cocaine caught me with a scale
i was arrested for the first time
i was sent to juvenile hall
i remember going through the whole
process of being booked in and
how horrifying it was for me
embarrassing being strip searched
having my mom and my aunt and my uncle
and here we are we just came out to
california and i was already in jail
and my mom got me out
and
my mom didn't want to face it she just
didn't want to see it and it wasn't her
fault because she didn't know how to
deal with it
and then i had to go through the whole
process of school and i was expelled
from school
had to go to court
and i was expelled from india high
school
and i was off for a whole year
independent studies trying to work my
way back into school
and i tried my hardest and i went and i
did good i stayed away from the drugs i
stayed away from the people
and i said that's it i'm just not going
to do this anymore
and so i was allowed back into palm
desert high school i had to go to
another high school
and i started real good i was doing
great i was
a junior in high school and i was i was
doing great at a new school i stayed
away from the drugs i got into sports
and athletics and i've always been in
sports and athletics throughout my life
so i loved the game of football
and i just poured my life into football
but at home i was still troubled
i remember
at a young age
i'd be like listening at night and i
would hear my mom crying
and i couldn't understand what it was
and then i realized my father would just
drink too much and get into a fight with
my mom and then i would get so upset
about it
that one day i tried to protect my mom
and i said you can't do this no more to
my mom
and i put her behind me
and i remember trying to be the
protector of my mom
that's all i wanted to do is keep my mom
safe and my
and my dad wasn't having it
and uh at a young age i think i was
maybe 15 or
a little after 15 my dad
asked me to leave he threw me out of the
house
and uh
i just got in my vehicle i had a little
blazer i had a broken leg at the time
and i i and i and i had a girlfriend at
the time and i was that was the first
time i was ever homeless
and i didn't know what to do i just
slept in the back of my blazer and
hoped nobody would find out at school
and because i was really good on the
football team i think my athletic
director kind of knew what was going on
and he just didn't say anything
and um
the girlfriend i had at the time
her father
found out about it
and he decided to reach out and help me
and he let me stay in one of the rooms
in their house as long as i had an
agreement that i wouldn't
mess with his daughter or do anything at
the house and tom was a beautiful man
and angie was my girlfriend at the time
and
you know i found a home it uh
you know i just wanted to finish school
i didn't
i didn't want to drop out because i knew
that the other way of life just wouldn't
work
and so they took me into their home and
i was able to get my school under
control nobody really questioned
anything that was going on and i was
really doing good in sports
i really had a chance i thought man i'm
going to go to college i'm going to get
out of this i'm going to change my life
i'm i'm not going to be that person i
don't want to fail i just i want to win
in life i don't want to fail anymore
and um
it looked like i was going to be able to
play for san diego state
and then uh
they came to me and they the athletic
director came to me at the school and
said uh
cif is not gonna let you play your
senior year
and i said why if i don't play my senior
year i'm never gonna get to college
they said well mark you got in trouble
you were arrested for selling drugs
and i said i know but i stopped
and they said well you went on
independent studies
and you went too many quarters over
so we're not gonna let you uh play
football anymore
and uh the only way to fight it is if
your
parents
came to the cif
to plead your case
but i didn't want to let them know i
wasn't living with my parents
and i was upset at my father and i was
upset at my mom
and i i just didn't talk to them
so long story short um
nobody ever showed up
uh
to talk to the state
and to talk to cif
so they rolled against me and i couldn't
play my senior year
so i gave up on my hopes
i went to work for um angie's father
he had an electrical company and i went
to work as an apprentice
angie and i got married out of high
school
and i just
gave up on my dream of playing college
football and i figured it was just right
to just go to work
auntie and i had a child together
i was young i think i was we were just
out of high school maybe 19 20 years old
joshua was his name
and that was my first son
and then everything started falling
apart and unraveling at work because i
wanted to leave
working with tom start my own company do
a little advertising agency i wanted to
be an entrepreneur and get out of my own
and do something myself
and that fell apart i didn't have the
experience and the knowledge but i had
the desire i wanted to be something more
in life i just
i always was striving to be something
better
and through that dispos that when that
business closed and we bankrupted it i
tried to get back in several fixed
relationship with my father-in-law
and angie was just falling farther and
farther away from me
and and
i realized in my life i don't do good
with loss
because it reminds me too much of my
childhood
and i started drinking heavy again for
the first time
and i went and got any job i could and i
was working at dominoes and trying to
support my wife and my son and
somebody introduced me to cocaine again
and it wasn't on a massive scale because
i don't think my dependency grew that
much at that point
then i came home and angie told me look
my mom and dad want to move to colorado
if you want to see your son
and you want to be around him we need to
move to colorado
and i didn't want to lose my son because
i always wanted to be the father
to him that i never felt i had and i
wanted to do everything for him that i
never had
so we moved all the way out to colorado
within
two to three weeks when i got to
colorado i had nothing but that and i
was living under their roof i didn't
have a job yet
and angie woke me up and said you know
what
you have to leave
i said what do you mean she said i just
this isn't going to work anymore
and i kissed my son goodbye i had
nowhere to go i came all the way out
here to california
and
the family i tried to create
i
it just went away i lost it and i lost
my son
and uh
she didn't want anything to do with me i
went out there a couple times to find
her and she moved
i came back to california
i got uh
introduced to cocaine i went back to
domino's pizza and i got introduced to
cocaine and i just started using
for the first time like just using
then i couldn't pay for it then i found
out how to sell it then i started
selling it and using more and i gave up
my job and i got with a girlfriend
and then everything just fell apart in
my life it was the first time that i
really became chemical dependent on
cocaine
because i could not
deal with the fact that i lost my son
and i started smoking crack
for the first time in my life and i
became
so dependent
i was 160 pounds
160 pounds
but i didn't want to live
and i couldn't deal with the pain of the
loss
and so
then i got introduced to
methamphetamines and i started using
meth and i started dealing and i started
doing all the criminal activity that
comes along with it
and eventually it caught up to me like
everything does
and i was arrested for sales and
transportation
and they caught me driving in a car with
a trunk full of weed
in
in the 90s it was kind of different than
it is today in the 90s you get caught
with drugs and
you were going to prison
you were going to prison
and there i sat in jail
for the first real time i was in county
jail
and i never forget when the public
defender came to me and said the best i
can do for you is two years in prison
and my world just stopped
just
stopped and i couldn't believe that i
was facing that and i never knew growing
up that that would be the end result
and i went to prison for the first time
in 1992
the first time of many more to come
and i was scared
all these horrible stories you hear
about prison i was scared
i was a young man going to prison
and i went to prison
right across from chino state prison
california rehabilitation center hotel
california for my first term
and i did two years and the horrible
stories were true
but when i went there i was so scared i
was just trying to get through and not
get caught up and then back then there
was so much segregation and racism and
there was so much ugliness in riots on
the yard and
it just scared me to death
and i paroled
thank god my mom and dad allowed me to
parole to their house
and i and i paroled with the best
intentions i'm never going to do this
again
i'm never going back
that was a horrible experience
but what i didn't realize how it just
kind of shaved away the consequences a
little for me because now i'd already
been there
and i tried to get going i tried to get
i got a great job selling cars
i thought i found my thing
and then the dmv sent me a letter in the
mail and said
once again
can't let you work there
why
because you were arrested
you're arrested transporting drugs you
can't do it and then i found myself
without a job
found another girlfriend
then i started to say okay well let me
just get another business let me try to
open a company
got with a partner to help you know do a
little entrepreneur endeavor because i
was convinced that i would never get a
job i did really good on parole i never
violated my parole i always tested clean
but the cycle was already starting to
unravel
started a company started a little
vending route i was doing great
and in my relationship i started
drinking again and it always starts with
a drink i started drinking again
that relationship fell apart the
business fell apart and here i was faced
again with losing everything one more
time
and as i look back in life i i see like
every time i'm faced with that and i
start losing everything again
here comes the drugs
here comes the selling of the drugs
here comes the subculture of living on
the street
running around with gangsters and
living the the outlaws life
and really i'm just masking all my pain
and just trying to get high
because i was just hurting too much
to face my life
and once i started getting high and i
started using drugs and nobody wanted
anything to do with me
started running around on the streets
one more time and i got caught again for
selling drugs
this time i was back in county jail
but what was funny about this time it
was the second time that i was going
upstate and i sometimes you're sitting
in county jail and you just feel a
little relieved that it's just
it's over it's i'm going to prison one
more time
and they gave me another prison term
and i went to prison going oh my god
here i go again
how did i get here
and it was the drug use
and i went to a little bit of a harder
prison this time
tachipie state prison
and i served two years
and i got out
and i paroled
and i don't get into all the horrible
stories because we all know the horrible
stories of prison
and the gangs inside and
doing everything you can just to stay
alive and
race riots and horrible things you see
and witness
it just burns that into you and then you
just become institutionalized
after i paroled and i got out on the
street i tried to do good and then i
just gave up easier and quicker this
time
and i just said what's the sense
and i was almost becoming
institutionalized without even realizing
it
and my second and third term came
quick and the third term again was
transportating drugs and
selling drugs and the dereliction of it
and running it around
i got caught again and i was heading to
prison for the third time
and i did a third time in a little bit
of a harder prison
and i got out one more time and i
paroled and i did good on parole but in
between those two prison terms i never
got off parole because i just gave up
and the third time i tried again
and then i was wanted one more time
because i ran
and i started using drugs and i started
getting back with the old people and i
started selling drugs and getting in
trouble and running around and getting
into crime getting into stealing dealing
with you know commercial robberies and
it seemed like every time i just became
worse and worse
and worse
and then i got my fourth term which was
five years
and i looked back and i thought
all those years 12 years went by and i
saw my mom twice
two christmases and that's it it was
just constant in and out of prison in
and out of prison in and out of prison
and this last term was in solidarity
state prison
in a cell
in a very hard prison
and i and and i don't even know i look
back and i think how did i get through
all that with
all the riots and the violence and it
was five tiers high and you can just
hear the pain and you could hear the
screaming and you could see people being
hurt
in the riots and the fights and the
stabbings and the killings and the just
all that horrible stuff that i witnessed
i remember one day i was on the yard
we're out there in the main yard and
we're just everybody's exercising and
working out and doing their pull-ups and
push-ups and everybody's segregated and
we're using the outdoor restroom and i'm
sitting next to my friend josh and i'm
right here and there's another guy right
here and he says look out mark and the
guy just comes along and just cuts the
guy right in the throat
and just that guy ran and and he died
right there in the yard and i couldn't
believe i'm right in the middle of this
i'm like what am i doing here
what am i doing here and am i going to
be able to get home safely
i had no idea where i was going to
parole i had no idea
and my sister carol just was
a unicorn at that time and said parole
to my house
when i got out i paroled to the house
and i thought i would go to the higher
desert victorville barstow area maybe a
changed geographical change would do me
good
and i went to college i went to junior
college and i tried to finish the dream
i originally had as a young man
and sure enough right there at college
somebody offered me drugs and i started
using drugs again
and the whole spiral happened again and
i wound up moving back down to the
desert to get with all the old friends
and get in trouble one more time
and um
that's when i really started
experiencing homelessness myself
because nobody wanted anything to do
with me
my drug addiction had taken over
my alcoholism had taken over
in 2009 i found myself living underneath
a bridge
jackson street bridge
and i had a broken foot
i broke my hand trying to defend myself
getting in fights and all the stuff that
goes on with the homeless community
and there was a little
alcoves little cutouts underneath the
bridge so you could just go up there and
just sleep at night
and uh
there i was homeless
and i come from a good family
you know my brothers and sisters are
very successful
they all have good careers
and uh
i had a troubled youth but
there's more trouble
out there that people experience
and there was no
understanding
i was homeless under a bridge and i had
nowhere to go
walking around the city streets of indio
i was arrested one more time
and in jail somebody
a guy wrote me a little note and he said
uh
you have two problems mark
you need to end your homelessness then
you need to find your way find god do
something mark you have to change your
way
i remember coming out of jail it was hot
my foot was broken i had no shoes no
socks
i looked at this little map
i looked to the left and i saw the
liquor store i knew where the friends
were
there's a little map to a rescue mission
and i said man i got to change
and that was the first time that i
really really felt that i needed to
change where i wouldn't live anymore
so i walked all the way down there and i
had a stop every time my foot was
hurting and i and i went to that rescue
mission and i experienced recovery for
the first time
and i lived in that over overnight
shelter and i didn't want to leave
no matter what
but all of my past caught up to me
i got a warrant
i was in a high-speed chase
i ran from the police
they had me on a warrant for 459
commercial burglary
and i had to go to court and face
criminal charges one more time
but instead of sending me to prison for
the fifth time the judge decided to give
me a court-ordered program called drug
court
and i really started to understand
what recovery was
and i really believed in like
i started believing in myself again
i started saying okay well
that's my life but it doesn't have to be
my tomorrow
you know your past doesn't dictate your
future and i tried my hardest and i
found a home there
at the rescue mission
in india
and i was exposed to other people and as
i grew in my sobriety and i had to go
through all these court cases and i had
to
fight my way out of it and uh
go to prop 36 and dui classes and drug
court and exposed to aaa meetings in
church and
i started realizing there's more to it
and then i remember helping one person
one person that was homeless and
encouraging them
and somehow it made me it made me feel a
little bit better
i couldn't explain it i didn't know what
was going on at the time but i shared a
little bit of my story and i was able to
say you know what i've been there and it
encouraged him to stay
and i started making more friends and
then i realized
wait a minute
here that kind of makes me feel a little
bit
good or better about myself but maybe
all the things that i did in my life
wasn't so horrible and that was my first
exposure to just helping another person
and they just found a way to keep me
there
you know they gave me a part-time cook
job
i just started cooking food for the
homeless so we'd make pizzas on the
weekends and it made me feel good and
then i worked at a gas station and i
graduated the program and then i started
working in the overnight shelter and i i
went there to help to get help i just
needed a place to stay i didn't realize
that
along the way and in my journey i would
find something to do
and i found employment there
and then we went from the small mission
to a really big mission next door and we
had a real real big building we raised
the money for it and uh
we moved from that old little mission
and i always stayed around the mission
they always found a reason for me to
stay there
and i started working with
the homeless population
in 2009 2010
was a lot different than it is today
and so we just started working with them
i graduated the program i started really
doing good i
i found my girlfriend francis
was my wife today
and um
i was living i moved out successfully
and uh she came home one day and said
i'm pregnant
and uh
i couldn't believe it because after i
lost joshua
at a young age i promised myself i would
never have a kid again
because i never wanted to experience
that loss
and so moving forward i was clean and
sober and i was doing good and i had
year after year after year of sobriety i
went back to school to study it to be
able to help people more
and i loved what i did working and i
worked in the emergency shelter i worked
with guys in the program
frances and i
we we had our son and
one of the most hardest points of that
whole pregnancy was finding out that my
son had a birth defect
that he had gastrostasis and all his
intestines were on the outside of his
body
but we had our son
he made it through
little mark junior
and
[Music]
fast forwarding it to like 2015 you know
14
13 14 and 15 was really good we had our
own place everything was going well
and then francis and i
just we're not getting along
and we had problems and we split up
and looking back that was what was
starting to trigger
myself to unravel
and everything i saw went right out the
door one more time
and frances and i separated
and my son went with her
i didn't use at the time i didn't
relapse i didn't start drinking again i
just kept working and working and trying
to create a life that would be
understandable and then have another
girlfriend and just hopefully
that just never worked out
and we just separated and we went our
own separate way
and i didn't realize it then but my ego
and my pride and my work
was becoming my identity
and i was slipping in so many ways
that my life was spiraling out of
control one more time with the
separation of my wife i was slacking on
my job i was becoming bigger than myself
and i had no humility
and so roughly around 2015
um
my job came to an end
i went to work one day
they terminated my position and let me
go all of a sudden
all of a sudden they let me go i'm at
eight years of sobriety eight years
i just bought a house
i bought a house because i believed that
my family would come back together
someday and my kids would have a home to
grow up and it wouldn't have to go
through what i went through as a child
one more time
losing the house getting evicted not
having a place to call home so i thought
that
i'm gonna get this home and that somehow
my family's gonna come back together
but the loss of my job the loss of my
identity i was not processing things
correctly i stopped going to meetings i
stopped doing everything that kept me
clean and sober for that entire eight
years
i just bought a new truck everything was
going great
i drive to am pm
to put gas in my car
i walk in the store
i look to the right and there's the beer
aisle
and i walk over i open the door and i
grab two 40-ounce beers
eight years of sobriety
eight years of sobriety
i sat in my car
and i drank the first one
and i thought to myself
what did i just do
i just lost eight years of sobriety
and i just said the heck with it and i
drank the other one
and i went home and i just started
drinking
all over again
everything just went right out the
window
within two to three weeks
i was introduced to somebody around the
corner that had methamphetamines they
said hey do you want some and i knew the
answer i knew what to do
so i started smoking methamphetamines
one more time
and all of the guilt
all of the shame
all the hiding from everybody
because i didn't want anybody to know
that i slipped and i relapsed i'm
drinking and using after spending all
those years working with so many people
having my life together now i was right
back to where i was in 2009
but i wasn't able to stop
once i took that drink once i was drunk
once i was loaded on drugs i could not
stop
and in
2015
2016 i relapsed
and
it just became
absolutely
horrible
i went right back to all the old guys i
used to traffic drugs for and sell drugs
for
i couldn't get high anymore
and then i
started using heroin
because
the guilt the shame
the hard times i had
once i used heroin for the first time
everything went away
all my pain
everything went away so now i'm on
heroin i'm on meth i'm on alcohol the
expense of it all
i start selling drugs
to pay for my habit i ran out of all my
money
i'm not making any payments
on my house on my car on the water bill
nothing i'm hanging around
horrible people
gang members
troublemakers
the underground the whole subculture of
selling drugs using drugs white-collared
crimes credit card fraud
selling stolen stuff
breaking into places stealing
getting involved with that whole network
of criminals where
you're stealing stuff to get high and
they're stealing your stuff to get high
dealing with all kinds of drugs
and the whole time
the whole time
all i'm doing is every now and then i
have a moment of clarity where i go
man
what am i doing but i just can't stop
i just can't quit i tried a couple times
to quit on my own
a good friend of mine
troy who's my coach
who's a dear friend
was my coach
in life
when i was at my last couple years the
mission and working at the mission
knew that i relapsed but i was too
embarrassed to tell him i didn't want to
talk to him i was so angry at him
because i blamed him
i blamed the mission i blamed everybody
for my relapse
i remember one time he called me and i
was so mad at him i was yelling at the
phone and i wasn't mad at him i was mad
at myself
i threw the phone out the window
and he just
troyas got tenacity and he just would
not stop
he'd find my new phone number and he
keep trying but i didn't want to listen
to him
did not want to listen to troy i wasn't
ready to stop drinking and using
along with my drinking and using came i
got arrested in my front yard
they found drugs in my car
i was being watched by the police
i got in terrible accidents
i remember one time i was driving down
the street at 45 miles an hour on
jefferson and i fell asleep i hit the
back of a truck totaled the truck ran
from the police
they found me i got arrested that's
twice
i bailed out
i'm selling drugs i'm doing everything
that is 100 wrong everything that i
stood for went right out the window in
order to get high
i tried getting sober i couldn't get
sober
i knew that i was
everything was coming to a close
when i got loaded and i got
drunk one more time i remember telling
francis my wife i said
francis
please don't come around me
please don't come around me i'm no good
i'm selling drugs i'm a horrible person
and i don't want you or the kids to see
me loaded because she never did
the whole time we were together we were
sober she never saw a drunken loaded
mark
never
and i remember one day the knock came at
the door
and like who's there and she said it's
frances and i said
you have to go away
and she said no
but i was so full of shame because of
all the
horrible stuff i was into
i didn't want her to see me
i couldn't open the door
and she sat outside for
six or eight hours and i told her please
just go away francis leave me alone i'm
no good just let me die let me just
stay away from me
and she said
i'm not leaving you're the man i love
and you're the man i married
and that was like getting close to the
end of my relapse because i was out
there for like 14 months
and everything i lost everything i
totaled every car
i've stolen i've broken into places i've
sold drugs i've hung around the most
horrible people
and everything was coming to a close so
fast
and i i let her in
and she said i don't get it i said i
relapsed
i've been doing everything wrong and i
don't know how to stop
and she tried with the best of her
intentions to try
but i wasn't listening
and i would like to say hey everything
stopped and i got cleaned and sober and
everything came back together and
everything was wonderful warm and fuzzy
but it wasn't
i did not stop i was chemically
dependent at that time on heroin meth
and alcohol and i needed to get high
every day to feel well and to be able to
get through my day and then all of the
horrible people started coming around i
got in trouble again i got arrested one
more time
the police were closing in on me
i was in
circles of drug traffickers drug dealers
gang members i was trying to go all the
way to san diego and move drugs just to
be able to get caught up in my mind i
was thinking i just need to get caught
up get ahead and then i'll go get help i
don't want to lose my house i don't want
to lose the last thing i have in this
world i just don't want to lose anything
more i'm tired of losing my whole life
that's all i ever felt like i was just
everything i had everything that ever
mattered to me i always lost no matter
what i remember coming back all the way
from san diego and i was driving all the
way down highway 74.
i fell asleep
i caught a nod
i woke up and i was driving right off of
74.
and i drove right off of 74 airbags
deployed
hit me i went off of 74.
two rocks kept me my vehicle from going
all the way down i kicked the door open
i climbed all the way back up i didn't
want to call the police i didn't want to
go to the hospital i'm drunk i'm loaded
i have drugs on me all the time 24 hours
a day
i hitchhiked all the way home
got home and what did i do
i continued to get high
i was just
out there no matter what happened
all the horrible stuff all the arrows
pointing
that i needed to stop drinking i needed
to stop using and i still didn't
i still did not
and then i started getting into guns and
then i started having guns around the
house and i figured okay well let's just
sell guns let's sell drugs let's do
whatever we had to have money
everything was just falling apart i had
so many horrible people around me i just
didn't even know what to do so i just
kept using and consuming drugs and
getting farther and farther and farther
behind
i had a wonderful idea
uh i looked back and i think what was i
thinking at the time
somebody else said hey let's just go
rob this store over here verizon and we
can get some phones and we can get
caught up and spend money
and then we hatched this plan
we cut through the wall and went to rob
a verizon store the alarms went off we
didn't get caught right then and there
but
obviously they have cameras they knew
who did it
i'm driving i'm leaving my house i'm
going down the street and the cops swarm
on me
and they catch me with drugs and needles
and hypodermic needles in my car and
they arrest me one more time
this is coming to the back end of my
relapse
it's still i get out on bail i go home
what's the first thing i do i get high
some more
i just i cannot stop using i just keep
using i keep smashing down the pain
so i've spoken about troy before and i
have a life coach that really believes
in self-care
really believes in working out and
taking care of yourself and back then i
didn't quite grasp the concept as i do
today
and one time we were hiking on the
bumping grind
it's a big mountain that everybody calls
a bumping around and we're hiking and
we're coming down this mountain
and this is before i lost my job troy
turned to me and he said mark i don't
know anything about this drug stuff i
don't know i've never done it i i have
no idea i'm totally totally a myth i
have no idea
but what if mark i said what if what do
you mean
what if you were able to relapse what
should i do
i said ah i'm never gonna relapse
there's no way my ego and pride was in
the way
and sure enough
at the end
i get a call from troy
i go hello
this is troy i go i don't know a troy
here talk to this guy he gives a call
that phone back he goes mark you don't
know me
and i said hi troy i know you
i'm just too full of shame and i'm
embarrassed
and troy started just talking to me a
little bit
but then again i just kept on using i
did not want to stop
i didn't want to stop
francis started coming around more with
the kids
i started trying to stop i started
to try to have my family back together
with my step-daughter
ellie and junior
and francis and everything got bad i
just couldn't stop drinking i was
getting angry at her we were fighting we
were having all kinds of problems
the house was extremely risky with a lot
of dangerous people around
and
one day troy came
he came all the way from oregon
and he said uh
i said troy why are you here
look at me look at what i've become
look at my my life is a ruin i ruined
everything i threw everything away troy
he goes i go why are you here
and he said mark
do you remember when we were hiking that
day i said yeah
he goes i made you a promise
and i'm here to live up to my word i
promised you i would come down here
and he was there
and he took me out back he said you know
what mark this isn't you this is a drug
induced
alcohol written mark but it's not who
you are
you have to stop
go somewhere and find help
and i would like to see right then and
there
everything stopped
and i got well but i did not and
everything happened quickly within two
weeks
and then
one night
i was drinking and i was using
and it felt like my life was out of
control
felt like i didn't want to live anymore
and i had a loaded 45 on my
bureau and i had a bottle of whiskey
and i was up for way too long
and i just wanted to end my life i just
i didn't want to live anymore i didn't
want to deal with the guilt the shame
the worry the frustration
i'm 48 years old and i'm
i'm just a loser i lost everything
and i remember i would i had my bible i
had a alcoholics anonymous book and i
was trying to read
i was trying to change my life i was
trying to pull out of it
and i flipped through the pages of the
bible and my son's picture came out
and i thought
i can't do this
i can't leave my son alone
i can't
i won't leave without a father
and i would like to say everything ended
right there for me
and i all i could say was
god help me and uh
i finally fell asleep
and when i woke up i got all that stuff
out of the house
troy came back around and said man
we need to help you mark you need to
change
i said but i lost everything i lost my
why even why does it matter twice and
because you're better than this
and then everything started rolling fast
and he said you go anywhere mark
you go anywhere and you can get into any
detox you tell him to call me and i'll
pay the bill
you gotta change mark
and then troy worked with a friend of
mine from the county that helped me get
into a detox
and troy set up
mark
on this day at 10 o'clock in the morning
i'm gonna be in your driveway
and you need to be there
and you need to get in my car at 10 and
we're going to go get you help and if
you're not there
we're done don't call me and i'm not
going to call you again
and unfortunately there was
a holiday it was a holiday
so i had to wait like three or four more
days because
the treatment center didn't have an
available bed
and i remember thinking
i'm not going to make it
i'm not going to make it
and i kept using
it kept using and kept getting high
i remember the day before the night
before
as crazy as my mind was i didn't even
know what date was
then the night before i went to score
some drugs and on the way home we got
chased
the police went to pull us over and i
thought to myself don't pull the car
over i have to go to treatment in the
morning
don't pull over and we ran
and we ran from the police
and we got caught
in the sand dunes and i jumped out and i
just started running
i just started running and running and
running and running
and i was so scared and i knew it was
getting late at night and i had to get
home
i walked through the desert
i mean all the way through the desert
hitched hiked rides walked home
i got home at like maybe seven in the
morning and francis was there and i said
francis please
don't let me fall asleep because i won't
wake up for troy
and sure enough 10 o'clock came and i
don't know what it was like i just
knew that if i did not get help
i would never live
i would never live i couldn't get
through it anymore
i had all these court cases i had the
police at both sides of my block
watching every move i made
it was horrible i never ever experienced
so much pain in my life
i fell asleep
but i woke up in time
but i was still sick as a dog off the
drugs i was sick
and i remember getting high and i was so
embarrassed to tell troy
and i just got as high as i could just
to get through the day
and i remember looking at francis and
the kids were there and i just said
i'm so sorry
i'm sorry for everything
but i'm going to make this right somehow
i'm going to make this right and i just
threw clothes grabbed my bag
and when i walked out of my house i knew
right there
i would never see my home again and i
would lose everything but i didn't care
because i didn't want to lose my life i
was done
and i got in that car with troy and we
went over to a county building
and they had to do all the assessments
and i
couldn't even
think i was so clouded with all the
detox and the horrible feelings i had
and everything i was going through was
just terrible
they were asking me questions i didn't
even understand what they were saying to
me
and they just heard me up and they said
go to the ranch
go to detox mark
and i got in the car and i remember
i couldn't even peel an orange that he
gave me to eat
i was so distorted
and that's
where the journey in my recovery began
i decided right then i needed to live i
didn't want to die
and troy was that person
that just kept trying and kept trying
and kept trying and i listened i heard
that voice inside of me that said man
you got to get help mark you've got to
stop what you're doing
and i went to um
i went to detox and again i'd like to
say like oh everything was wonderful but
it
it wasn't it was a horrible detox
it was 10 days
and i was shaking and it was hurting and
i just wouldn't accept anything
i wouldn't accept no drugs i said i
didn't come here to get andre off i came
here to get off of drugs not on
different drugs so i did everything cold
turkey
and then you wake up
the next morning and you're or the
second or the third morning and you
start facing reality
all the pain of everything you did
the guilt the shame the loss
everything i did came to light and i was
like i could not even believe all the
horrible stuff i did could not even
believe it
my hand
i hurt my hand right here
with a machete because on one of my when
i was high i thought oh well this is
great let's go chop down some weed
plants and let's make some money i
slipped and i fell and i cut my finger
almost cut my fingers off so my hand was
killing me
and i was hurting and i was coming off
all the drugs and i remember all the
hallucinations i was sweating and i
couldn't eat i was taking hot showers
back and forth to the nurse
but when the second the third and the
fourth day came
i started just taking a deep breath
and that's where my recruit recovery
started again
and that was on january 15 2018
that was my first day sober again after
14 months of my relapse
14 months
and the most difficult thing for me was
i didn't know where my wife and kids
were
because troy
he didn't tell me because the kids were
unsafe at the house and francis was
unsafe
and
uh so
i didn't know for the first 30 days
where my children were
but i just knew that
i had to stay there man
i had to get back into recovery
and what's funny is like i knew right
then and there i said in the beginning i
said i'm never going to go back i'm
never going to help people again i'm
done i eight years i served people and i
counseled and i just was so
mad at myself i felt like such a failure
i felt like i just let everybody down
and i was just done and
as that journey of recovery began
when i started helping people again i
felt that need like i felt that desire
to help people
and
all the other things came into play
my house was being foreclosed on and we
needed to sell it i had all kinds of
debt
the person that i hit when i fell asleep
in the car was suing me
and then i had all my court issues
i had three court cases
and it wasn't looking good
because i have a lifelong of prison i
have a 14 page rap sheet i have like 15
16 felonies there's no way that i'm
gonna get any mercy in the courts
but i knew that i had to go to court and
i remember going to court for the first
time
and the judge looked down at me and the
d.a looked over and he said is that mark
mcgowan
and they said yes and i remember what
they said what happened to him
because i used to go to court and people
they'd be released to my custody because
he knew we were doing good work to help
people
so
i'm at the ranch and i'm working through
it and i'm getting on my 30th day
then they have a center go up there and
test and then i find out i have
hepatitis c
from dirty needles exchanging needles i
contracted hepatitis c so i had to go
through hepatitis c liver treatment
i got on through through my treatment
phase
moved to a sober living house
and then i realized i had to have
reconstructive surgery on my hand from
the accident i had
and i was in that rehab
and i was in the sober living
and things were starting to come back
together but there's one story that i
forgot to mention was right at 30 days
30 days you're allowed to have visits
and i could get called up to the main
office
and i still don't know where my kids are
i still don't know where my wife is
and then walks francis and there's my
son
and he just dropped this
little tablet and ran over and hugged me
and that just made it all better and
ellie was there in junior and we had a
visit and for the first time i realized
i was clean and sober again and what was
most important in life
as your family
is my wife and kids
and she never left she just hung with me
and stayed with me through the whole
time
she never left
and we went through a lot of processes
there at the rehab and then we got into
a family program so we can get our
children the help they needed
as i moved through and i phased up and
i'm still going to court and i'm kind of
fast forwarding through it
and i'm moving
into another sober living house called
the noaa house where i'm
i'm living and it's it's sponsored by my
old place the coachella valley rescue
mission and
that's where francis went to live while
i was in treatment because they had no
choice and it was hard for me because it
was where i used to work
to know that my family had to go there
for protection and safety
and all of this was happening
sometimes very slowly and sometimes very
quickly
and and this was all in my first year of
recovery my first six months of recovery
was nothing but court appointments and
surgeries and
treatment and rehabilitation and i just
kept on saying no matter what i'm not
going to leave no matter what i'm not
going back
and troy was in
in my life more and he was working on
more things and i was getting back into
self-care and i was starting to become
alive again
and that happens over time because you
just
you lose your way you lose your soul you
lose
who you are and that's what drugs and
alcohol do to people and it just
it just gets you into this small
subculture of a world that when you come
out of it it takes time
it takes time for you to come back
around and you need to have a lot of
support around you
and i'm just grateful for troy because i
and i wanted to say this before is that
when you're working with somebody like
troy i must have said no detroit 12
times
but did that stop him no and he never
gave up
he always and i always tell people don't
give up on somebody you never you never
want to give up hope
you never you never want to stop calling
somebody because you never know when
this one time you meet with that person
and you may say the right thing and they
might be going through the right
experience and it just connects and they
go you know what i want to change and
they do change
and sometimes we do change and sometimes
we don't
but this is my story is just about
change at the right time but troy never
ever gave up on me and that's one thing
i want to let people know is don't give
up on people that you're working with
because nobody ever knows what it's
going to take or how is it going to take
it every individual is different but if
you have
a love for somebody or a care for
another human being always just keep
trying don't ever give up
you